hey everyone
welcome to direct path number 10.
if you haven't i highly encourage you to
check out the first nine direct path
videos
again what we are doing in this series
is we
are pointing to
the one end of the mountain
from all of these different faces
from all these different paths
and we mention all of these different
guide posts on these paths
through these direct path videos
and then you get to take whichever
signposts from the videos most resonate
with you
and add them into your process of god
realization
of union with the absolute
this direct path video is
high level
therefore it may highly resonate
with those that are in advanced stages
and it may be something that people
closer to the
beginner or intermediate stages may need
to revisit again
and we'll be doing blends across
beginner intermediate and advanced
stages
in order to really create a diverse and
robust
catalog of these different sign posts
across these different paths and faces
to the one end of the top of the
mountain
and for those that already know
the mountain itself is a dualistic
concession as in there is something to
do
there is something to seek we must seek
god realization we must seek the diamond
necklace that is already around our neck
whereas non-duality
is just is
and so ultimately in the intention
of direct path number 10
is to be able to
hold this ultimate integral truth of the
absolute both with and without
[Music]
attributes
so let's start with number one which is
the absolute without
attributes and just to be clear
the word absolute can in many ways be
interchanged with the tao
with source with infinity
with god with the universal wave
function
with multiverse with
any of these nomenclature or lexicon
that enables one to
relate to
the ineffable that is being discussed
here using
symbols
so the juxtaposition that is being
created which in itself is a concession
is that absolute both
with attributes and without
attributes and so we're starting with
without attributes
so this is known as nirguna brahmin or
para brahmin
so again without attributes
and this is what is
discussed as ineffable it's discussed as
formless it is discussed as
devoid of maya devoid of the
illusion devoid of the dream devoid of
the appearance
just the ineffable the formless
beyond all descriptions and
conceptualizations meaning
every single time that we try to use a
symbol
to describe it it is not that
and that's why lao tzu said that the tao
that can be named is not the eternal dao
and this is also the transcendental
truth
all right
two the absolute with attributes
okay so again the absolute tao
source infinity god
universal wave function multiverse now
we're
adding attributes to it we're using
symbols
and concepts and descriptors to describe
it to describe the ineffable to describe
the formless
to describe the way that these
appearances are being
expressed to describe these dreams and
these illusions
this is also known as saguna brahman
dualism walter russell calls it a
rhythmic
balanced interchange we've talked about
this
as two poles that are in
flux like an electromagnetism
in an ascension process to an attractor
and that attractor is the godhead
and that is the simplicity
of the appearances
the dream
in god's brain which is what this
is
undergoes another dream
and so you can tell that we're already
adding all of these attributes
so many attributes already added to it
to try and describe the ineffable
other descriptors slash attributes
slash concepts that are frequently used
are the words
seeking enlightenment
prosperity architectures what we mean by
that
is that the diamond necklace is already
around your neck
and this is why and that's the most
famous
quote of rumi that is so
salient and poignant to the nature of
our existence
that we seek externally just like in the
parable of the prodigal son
for happiness externally
we hit a breaking point and then we turn
inward and we recognize that
consciousness
awareness itself is it
that we are god the dao
source absolute
we are that ineffable undergoing
this appearance
and each one of those diamonds around
our neck is a unique refraction of the
source light
therefore this unit is experiencing
a unique refraction of the source light
compared to
each of your unique units
and that's very similar to the
pupil is that sharedness
whereas the iris is the unique
coloration
again these very explain like i'm five
child-like analogies for the nature of
reality
and so you can begin telling how this is
a concession
because the
idea of seeking
only the ignorant seek what is already
there
you already are the fish in the ocean
you already are
it there is nothing to seek there is
nobody here to become enlightened
yet at the same time we'll unpack this
in number three
where we're going to hold both the
non-dual and the dual
simultaneously
because that mountain is actually
quite important when somebody finds
themselves
suffering quite a bit suffering is like
the drill sergeant
and if there are these direct path
teachings and these teachings of these
other
of the perennial wisdoms by other people
around the planet
what happens is that that person
undergoing
a process of being the egoic contracted
energy of the separate entity
that is seeking sufferings acting like a
drill sergeant
and they're seeking and they're turning
away from the external to the internal
that these disseminations
of the different faces of that perennial
wisdom
help the seeker
pierce the veilless veil the gateless
gate
and to god realize
and therefore eradicate their suffering
and therefore
enable their prosperity and this is
where we get into the prosperity
architectures
because well-being prosperity abundance
flourishing on a planetary level where
all basic needs are met
all of the sustainable development goals
are met we have no poverty
we have clean water and sanitation
we have clean and affordable energy we
have
quality education
where we have the god realization built
in
to these virtual reality pedagogies for
children to undergo
at very very young ages
so there is no time for the egoic
contracted entity to even form
because right away from the youth
they're turning inward and
understanding the nature of
consciousness and reality
and this is a rational metaphysical
analyzation
whereas the absolute without attributes
is very much like a transcendental truth
the absolute with attributes is very
much like a rational metaphysical
analyzation it's like rationality
that is trying to add the descriptors
the concepts
to the ineffable to be able to in a
sense
even scientifically and spiritually try
to describe it
and in many ways it is helpful
and that's why we move on to
number three
which is the absolute both
with and without attributes
so this is what is called simultaneity
this is where you can have both not two
non-dual which is without attributes
as well as two which is
with attributes which is the dualistic
concession this is the reconciliation
of monism and dualism
this is what is meant by yoga or union
or mysticism or hypnosis all of those
terms
mean union those mean becoming one
becoming one with what become one with
the absolute become one with
god become one with tao become one with
source
with infinity and that's why
the formation of the yin yang was so
salient
because it is the reconciliation of the
monism
and the dualism in one symbol
so salient
and this is the ultimate integral truth
this is
simultaneity although there is a
dualistic concession
of this mountain we recognize that
the process of god realization for each
one of us
is so critical and we recognize
maximizing planetary prosperity is
so critical and yet we also recognize
non-duality
in the sense that it is
this appearance ineffable
no descriptors no concepts
so that's it
again our intention
was the absolute both
with and without attributes
again that without attributes being that
nirguna brahman para brahman
ineffable formless devoid of maya beyond
all descriptions conceptualizations a
transcendental truth
the absolute with attributes being the
saguna brahman
dualism rhythmic balanced interchange
two pulls in flux ascension to an
attractor
seeking enlightenment prosperity
architectures a rational metaphysical
analyzation
and the absolute both with and without
attributes
true simultaneity both not two and two
as a concession
yoga union mysticism hypnosis the yin
yang
reconciliation of monism and dualism the
ultimate
integral truth
thank you very much for tuning in i love
you very much
greatly appreciate you i would love to
hear where you're at in the comments
below
how this resonated like the video if you
brought your value subscribe if you
haven't and
share it with people that you know this
will resonate with
thank you again so much infinite love
peace
you